I do see a lot of people you know
overreacting um I and you know a lot of
blame goes on to Dak Prescott because he
is a quarterback and people look at his
playoff wins but we gave up over 40 plus
points what what do you expect Dak
Prescott to be do you expect him to be
Superman he cannot win games by himself
I've always said football is not a game
of one man it's a game of 22 men that go
on the field and you need to rely on
every 22 guys to win that game is not
relied on one individual two individuals
it's a team that can play together as a
group the best collectively not give up
big plays and not cost their team uh
first downs and things like that so I do
not put down Dak Prescott he is a All
Pro he is played a terrific game um
could have would have should have been
an MVP but he's not and to put that
narrative you know people want to drive
whatever narrative that fits best for
them and that's what I'm realizing about
this game of football football and
that's what kind of drives away the
happiness because people don't
appreciate how good someone has been um
they want to attack them for where
they're at or what they have done and
things like that um so I think that came
a long way um obviously one of his
better year since I've been with the
Cowboys so that Narrative of we wanting
a different quarterback or we want a
different guy I think he's been a great
leader uh whatever whatever however
y'all want to put that um
you know and and that just drives me to
I'm at complete peace you know and and I
say that because I don't think I've
could have done anything more to try to
uh win that game and that comes to
watching film with the other guys in the
room saying what I'm seeing being vocal
out there on the field um I was
completely at peace because I know I
don't have no regrets about how I
performed or what I put into the game
and uh you know and I appreciate what
really matters in life and as family uh
outside you know um I don't think that
game defined me at all I don't think you
know that moment uh defined me so I'm
completely at peace of how I went I
can't change uh how it went or you know
where it went so I'm completely at peace
I love where I'm at in life I love my
family and I love from where we're going
and I love how they're talking and how
we're going to look ahead
you know and that means I believe in
Mike McCarthy uh we won a lot of games
with Mike uh 36 wins uh under the belt
with Mike so you know hopefully uh he
could take us all the way and you know
we drive this culture and we Chang The
Narrative that people
have